listen we all need to live with pressure
and as well I think it's good for an
artist as well to deal with some
pressure and what you see is that you
know when an artist has great commercial
success it is a double-edged sword
because if an artist only produces for
the market and loses his creative edge
he loses everything he loses his the
essence of his work him itself and so
some artists have creatively died
because they just went on repeating and
repeating the same thing just because it
was working the true great artists are
those who constantly challenge
themselves and go on move on and he
invents themselves constantly I mean one
of the greatest 20th century American
artist Frank Stella who is vibrant now
in his 70s it produces some of the best
works he's ever done he hasn't SAT still
one second whenever something was really
successful in working he moved on to the
next thing and did something totally new
and constantly evolved that's what's a
truly great artist
you